[Musique]
bonjour est heureux de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau 7,8 aequo avec des
entreprises de renommée sur le
territoire telles que renault thalès ou
encore bouygues saint quentin en
yvelines est une zone attractive qui a
un oeil tourné sur le monde pour ce 7,8
échos focus sur les entreprises
internationales sur le territoire on
passe au sommaire et leur manne tighten
fabricant leader des produits de
fixation d'identification de protection
des câbles et de leur outil de connexion
nous verrons avec jean baptiste uhmann
son pdg comment l'entreprise basée à
trappes a su devenir une référence dans
son domaine
nous irons aussi à la rencontre
d'olivier 2 bunny fondateur de lingua
custodia l'entreprise saint-quentinoise
traduit des textes financiers et
souhaite exporter son concept en asic et
puis quelles sont les forces de saint
quentin en yvelines à l'international
éléments de réponse avec anne failli
directrice générale adjointe au
développement économique de
l'agglomération
tout d'abord faisons un point sur les
forces de saint quentin en yvelines le
nombre d'entreprises à capitaux
étrangers est souvent cité pour montrer
l'attractivité d'un territoire au niveau
mondial l'agglomération compte plus de
234 entreprise d'origine étrangère près
de treize mille cinq cents emplois
c'est près d'un emploi sur dix qui
dépendent entreprises à capitaux
étrangers
un territoire attractif qui permet à des
entreprises comme l heure mantei tonne
base et attrapes de s'imposer dans le
monde
focus sur cette société leader des
produits de fixation et de protection de
câbles
je pourrais vous présenter notre
innovante' arbeiten donc qu est un nul à
vannes qui nous permet de présenter tous
nos produits
il y à des câbles mais pas seulement la
fixation le repérage la protection
encore la gestion des files c'est cela
et leur manne title basée à trappes
depuis 2012 l'entreprise a su s'imposer
en france et dans le monde grâce à son
savoir faire
on a sept la matière première vierge ou
qu'on appelle vierge
les granulés comme cela on va acheter
les équipements déjà on les fabrique pas
nous mêmes on peut fabriquer quelques
moules chez nous mais des petits moules
la plupart du temps on les achète à
l'extérieur par renault ont fait la
maintenance l'entretien la mise au point
des moules
donc une fois qu'on a acheté tout ça on
fabrique les terres et en conçoit nous
mêmes les pièces qu'on fabrique et la
méthode est payant chaque semaine
l'entreprise sera environ 14 millions de
pièces par semaine
un travail qui séduit des entreprises
comme airbus psa ou encore renault ce
qui plaît aux entreprises c'est la
capacité de leur manne teyton à
s'adapter à tous les secteurs on s'est
développée même pour l'isolation il faut
une pièce mouiller thermorétractable en
fonction du besoin du client
donc on peut aller très loin on l'a on a
parlé des électriciens mais on peut
aussi être sur le marché aéronautique
ont travaillé sur les moteurs donc à des
hautes températures on s'adapte en
fonction des matières qu'il ya des
différends voltage des résistances au
gasoil ou autres donc on sait tenir un
cahier des charges développer un produit
pour le pôle clients non vraiment de la
customisation
l'entreprise est en constante évolution
depuis six ans la croissance de la
société et de 10% et leur manne tighten
devrait atteindre 1 milliard de chiffre
d'affaires en 2010 7
nous sommes avec monsieur où mène le
directeur général des nordmann tighten
france bonjour vous avez un rayonnement
au niveau international expliquez-moi
pourquoi quels sont vos forces et
l'amateur est un groupe international
nous avons quinze usines dans le monde
37 filiales donc des usines en amérique
du nord en amérique du sud afrique du
sud en asie japon corée du sud chine
et puis en europe avec des usines en
angleterre en france en allemagne et
puis en pologne vraiment à rayonnement
international qui nous permet d'être
proche de nos clients notamment les
clients automobiles comment vous avez
fait pour vous développer
comme ça vous êtes imposé avec certains
produits alors notre métier c'est la
gestion des cas nous sommes spécialistes
de la gestion des câbles nous allons
identifier un câble le protégé
l'identifier dans l'automobile dans les
contreforts par exemple des portes votre
voiture vous avez des faisceaux de
câbles il va falloir les fixes et les
protéger les identifier donc ça c'est un
premier métier dans lequel nous sommes
tous 8e mondial pour être un acteur sur
ce métier il faut avoir des usines dans
le monde entier il est capable de
fournir une pièce aussi bien au japon
aux états unis qu'en europe c'est la
raison pour laquelle celle de model town
nous avons cette crise est ce
rayonnement à partir de la france par
exemple nous exportons en chine
donc c'est amusant de voir qu'une
entreprise de trappes exporte en chine
que c'est encore possible ça ce rêve la
halle l'entreprise de trappes qui tous
les arabes étrangers oui c'est possible
parce que nous avons des ingénieurs
développement une quinzaine ici à
trappes qui sont experts dans le
développement de nouvelles pièces qui
correspondent à des besoins clients
ces besoins sont exprimés sur des
plateformes qui sont aussi bien en
france en allemagne et en chine en
amérique du sud
donc cette pièce on va en avoir besoin
dans le monde entier être ici à trappes
avec comme vous l'avez dit psa de
technos entre nous ça ça a permis aussi
d'accélérer les choses saint quentin en
yvelines et bien situés on est proche de
paris on est proche des aéroports
on est proche de la vallée de chevreuse
c'est tous ces avantages directs
compétitif qui font que c'est une belle
région où êtres et où l'industrie
automobile s'est installée pas que on
trouve aussi à airbus par exemple
et à nos clients donc c'est une région
qui a des atouts compétitifs très
importante en chiffres à l'international
ça vaut quoi alors le chiffre d'affaires
l'année dernière c'était 820 millions
d'euros de chiffre d'affaires la france
cette année l'année dernière pardon a
réalisé à réaliser 40 millions d'euros
chiffre d'affaires cette année on a un
budget de 44 qu'on est de 10 est en
train de dépasser puisqu'on a tendance à
45 millions donc l'année prochaine on
espère bien attendre encore l'année
suivante 50 millions d'euros
donc on est dans cette dynamique
j'imagine que d'autres entreprises à
l'international lorgne sur votre société
oui c'est vrai que c'est un moyen de se
développe mais doit être aussi à
l'écouté de ce qui se passe sur son
marché
qu'est ce que va être le véhicule
électrique demain qu'est ce que va être
le véhicule autonome
ce sont des révolutions qui arrivent et
donc on doit s'y préparer et savoir
quelle solution va pouvoir proposer pour
les marchés nouveaux et j'imagine que la
rigueur de vos produits dans une voiture
ou n'y a plus de chauffeurs la
maintenance apprend encore plus tout son
sens c'est vrai c'est ce que nous
demande le client en trappe on produit
40 millions de pièces par mois donc des
petites pièces et on nous avoir zéro
défaut qualité donc on est déjà dans
cette logique de la perfection parce
qu'on peut pas se permettre que ce soit
dans un avion ou dans une voiture
d'avoir une pièce défectueuse
merci monsieur m'a beaucoup
[Musique]
nombre d'entreprises innovantes
pullulent sur le territoire saint
quentinois
l'une d'entre elles lingua custodia une
entreprise qui traduit des textes
financiers lorgne aujourd'hui sur le
marché asiatique
faisons un point avec olivier de benoist
son fondateur
bonjour bonjour alors en quelques mots
présentez moi lingua que ce te dire
merci les gars costauds dia est une
société qui développe des moteurs de
traduction automatique sur mesure alors
un moteur de traduction c'est quoi
google translate ou google traduction
c'est un moteur de traduction
sauf que nous ce qu'on fait c'est qu'on
développe donc des google traduction
spécifiquement pour le domaine financier
soit par type de document bien précis
soit pour des clients qui nous en font
la demande
alors quels sont les clients qui peuvent
vous faire ce type de demande
alors les clients sont souvent des
grandes institutions financières ou les
directions financières de grandes
sociétés
on a comme clients le groupe axa par
exemple ou des sociétés comme le groupe
rothschild le crédit agricole qui est
ici d'ailleurs saint-quentin-en-yvelines
juste à côté
voilà ce genre de sociétés des sociétés
de gestion d'actifs comme sycomore asset
management ou d'autres peines à 2011
création de l'entreprise 2015 salaires
2016 ça a été une année importante pour
vous expliquer moi on a effectué une
levée de fonds pour nous permettre
d'accélérer commercialement on a fait
d'énormes investissements marketing et
on a obtenu notamment à la fin de
l'année dernière le prix de l'agefi de
la fim tech innovante de l'année 2016
allez parler - peu de l'année 2010 est à
venir qu'est ce qui va se passer on va
lancer deux nouveaux couples de langues
donc aujourd'hui on couvre le français
l'anglais l'italien l'espagnol
l'allemand et on a fait un gros gros
effort de r&d pour pouvoir traduire le
japonais et le chinois également hélas
souvent dans une optique de
compréhension donc l'aller les
institutions financières veulent savoir
ce qui se passe bien même vous voulez
acheter une société en chine il faut
traduire les rapports finaux vous l'êtes
vous devez traduire 50 rapport financier
pour faire une analyse si vous faites ça
en traduction humaine ça va vous coûter
une fortune
donc vous pouvez traduire tous
immédiatement donc le pour nous
l'objectif 2010 est c'est vraiment
l'asie et les langues asiatiques
eh bien merci merci beaucoup voici les
secteurs qui s'exporte à l'international
il y à l'automobile avec le technocentre
renault à guyancourt bmw france et
mercedes benz à montigny le bretonneux
l'aéronautique avec airbus à elancourt
et snecma magny les hameaux ou encore
l'énergie avec saipem à montigny ou
keaton à maurepas
pour en savoir plus nous allons
interviewés entre yves directrice
générale adjointe au développement
économique à saint quentin en yvelines
sur les forces du territoire
[Musique]
bonjour quelles sont les forces de ces
entreprises dites internationales
quand elle s'entoure pas saint quentin
en yvelines qu'est ce que ça apporte en
plus elle souhaite en effet trouvé à la
fois des clients des fournisseurs qui
qui connaissent le marché
elle fait aussi recruter des compétences
qui sont formés sur les spécificités de
ce secteur
donc ce qu'elle trouve à saint quentin
en yvelines c'est un pas que le terreau
pour pouvoir se développer que sont les
pays qui vit 50 en divine alors de façon
générale en ile de france comme en
france les deux premiers pays
investisseurs sont les états unis et
puis et puis l'europe de l'ouest là on a
quand même quelques spécificités à saint
quentin en yvelines
la première c'est d'avoir un des
investisseurs on va dire de l'europe du
nord donc essentiellement pays bas suède
qui sont présents à un niveau très
significatif sur cinquante ans plus tôt
dans les secteurs technologiques
on peut citer jabra ou ou doro qui est
plus spécialisée sur le marché de la
silver economy la deuxième spécificité
qui est aussi liée à notre présence dans
le secteur automobile c'est la présence
d'entreprises à kappelen
quels sont les points qui les attirent
au niveau immobilier les prix sont
attractifs aussi alors les critères
d'implantation on les connaît la
proximité et l'accessibilité la qualité
de
de la desserte en transports en commun
reste l'élément numéro un
étudiée par les entreprises lors de
leurs projets d'implantation le deuxième
élément c'est un élément qui est liée au
coût et ce coût est notamment fonction
de l'immobilier d'entreprise et ça que
nous avons la chance à saint quentin en
yvelines à la fois d'avoir un parc
immobilier de plus de quelle vague hull
6 millions de mètres carrés disponibles
sur sur le territoire de 150 mille
mètres carrés en projet on est sur des
coups qui sont de l'ordre de 230 euros
le mètre carré et par an ce qui est
extrêmement attractif à l'échelle de
l'île de france
et bien je vous remercie madame pays à
très bientôt ah bah pour les rh comment
analyser vos besoins en recrutement et
conduire efficacement vos entretiens
ce stage est proposé le jeudi 27 avril
de 9h à 11h il vous donnera les clés
pour mener à bien votre entretien où
vous recrutement cela se déroule au ski
cube abus en cours
deuxième date à noter réussissez vos
entretiens professionnels et répondez à
vos obligations légales
l'atelier s'adresse aux managers le but
vous donner les clés pour convaincre un
responsable des ressources humaines
l'atelier se déroule également au ski
cube le jeudi 18 mai de 9h à 11h30
c'est la france de ceux ci dessus était
qu'au prochain numéro le 4 mai bonne
journée à tous
[Musique]